l'océan
un endroit d'une incomparable beauté et
en cette journée mondiale des océans
nous célébrons cet immense écosystème où
vivent crustacés étoiles de mer planck
thoniers et céphalopode l'improbable
écureuils mara
et bien sûr les bouches de mer j'adore
ma vie mais il nous à partir de nous
unir et le trail est vrai ce monde
paisible et délicat
[Musique]
alors pour la journée mondiale des
océans
à vous de jouer pour garder nos océans
propre et prend congé maladie plat de
pommes les poires ou pts et de garrigue
et de toutes ces créatures marines
viennent vous ne manquez pas
bob l'eponge le film répond journaux
troubles j'adore ma vie je t'aime
tellement gary oublierai jamais jour on
s'est rencontré et escargots comment tu
t'appelles cas rien qui ne conçoit
copains suis rentré de barrer la route à
kari kari
non car ici plus cartoon ap
en 2020 les aventures commencent les
amis laissent pas les amis faire des
enquêtes dangereuse tout seul dans un
nouveau monde la cité perdue d'atlantic
city
on va pas perdre notre concentration
patrick c'est pas notre genre de perdre
avec un héros dit sir patrick sur lequel
on peut miser met tout sur le jeune
patrick sepa nc-17 s'écrit avec un an
tout suffisant pas l'épongé
le film éponge en eaux troubles ça va
être une super aventure entre copains
pour la vente hier patrick qui perd pas
ses locaux ça tombe bien je suis très
douée pour repasser
[Musique]